[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in jane slater she doesn't
deal with clicks she is clicks
nfl network reporter you can follow her
on
twitter at slater nfl all right
jane separate fact from fiction here
can you i i'm with you dan and you know
how this works you've been
doing uh covering the league long enough
you've been
keeping an eye on the cowboys long
enough anytime you put the dallas
cowboys
in a headline people are going to talk
about it
and so we're talking about this because
a report came out from adam schefter
that he would entertain
a trade if it was dallas and the cowboys
so of course now it's the off-season we
haven't heard a lot about this debt
contract
so now everyone's talking about it but
when i reached out to one of my team
sources they found it laughable and
that's because they are still
trying to truly get this long-term deal
done and we're looking at the tag being
somewhere around 37.7 million dollars
we are going to probably hear something
about that closer to that tag deadline
of
march 9th and then they're going to have
to clear some cap space by march 17th to
start really
effectively having those long-term
discussions and then they of course shut
this thing down
in june i don't think he's heading for a
third tag
they can still do that that third tag is
going to be somewhere in the market of
54
million dollars which is absurd um
they could of course give them the
non-exclusive tag that gives them five
days to match an offer from another team
and then possibly pick up two first
round
compensatory picks but the goal here is
still to get him signed to a long-term
deal and
why would they continue using these
costly tags on him if they didn't
feel like he was their franchise guy and
oh by the way last year's money
was in the ballpark of russell wilson
jared goff type money now he's looking
to be paid right behind patrick mahomes
a guy who's gone
to the super bowl two years in a row dak
hasn't done that yet so they feel like
it's been a respectable offer
his camp believes that he needs to bear
what the market value
is and they feel like this deal should
have gotten done
two years ago so your problems with
money aren't our problems it's about
respect so
there still is no change from last year
in years past dan
there has to be some give by both sides
in order to get this done
but i truly feel like they want to get
it done and as i was
told by a team source it feels and their
tone kind of went up a bit
a little bit more productive but there
still haven't been a lot of meaningful
conversations
why do you think russell wilson's agent
named teams
well for the reasons we just outlined
there earlier i think you name
teams the saints for instance that
sounds like a great destination for a
guy like russell wilson
but when those teams consider it
or they pick up the phone their next
question is well how much is this going
to cost us
and i keep bringing up seattle versus
dallas because
seattle's front office has made a lot of
potential trades very costly for dallas
and i mentioned earl thomas last week
i mentioned jamal adams now he was of
course with the jets
cowboys and good faith tried to go after
him seattle jumped in and said
we'll pay you what you want then i was
told
that the seahawks wanted alden smith
last year the cowboys in that experiment
wasn't exactly working at times last
year there was a disruption in the ph
balance with some of the free agents
could have gotten rid of them then their
answer was
no in other words they're gonna either
resign him or
they'll find a way to move him off the
books and they get a compensatory pick
but because it was seattle the deal
didn't get done
well you also have russell wilson the 39
million dollar cap hit
i i i don't think russ is it's weird it
feels like
russ and his agent won it both ways hey
we want to stay in seattle but if you
want to trade us here are the four teams
that we're going to go to
but i do think the cap hit is really
important jane
i love that you bring that up because a
lot of people love to come up with these
i'll borrow phrase from mike mccarthy
last year you know some of you guys are
playing fantasy football
you know as it related to what he would
do with his offensive line i'll do that
as it relates to
russell wilson and whatever team whether
it be dallas or another
trading for him seattle also is on the
hook for his guaranteed money
so seattle's gonna be okay giving him
the guaranteed money and
especially go and win in another nfc
with another nfc team that we're gonna
have to play
a couple years down the line now look
could the cowboys tweet the deal and say
all right
we're gonna convince stack to sign the
franchise tag which again is just
crazy to me we'll convince him to sign
the franchise tag and then we're going
to
get his approval to trade up but we're
also probably gonna have to give up some
other things
that comes with dak so it's asset heavy
to move russell wilson off the books i
think this is a missive
i think this is a way of saying pete
carroll get on the same page
with russ either let russ cook find a
way that you guys can make this offense
work
but when you bring up dallas could it
happen with another team absolutely sure
we've seen these sort of trades happen
um we've certainly seen jared goff go to
detroit and matt stafford
uh come to la these things happen just
specifically with the with the cowboys
and people i've spoken to
and the way the money uh bears out it
just absolutely makes no sense and a lot
of people i love coming at me on twitter
and
uh wanting to tell me ways that they've
figured out it can happen
i'm telling you it can't happen we're
talking to jane slater nfl network
reporter
uh help me understand drew brees's
situation with new orleans of
what is he waiting for to make his
announcement one way or another
great question because if you'll recall
last year
we were sitting here having this i feel
like it's sort of groundhog day for me
as it relates to the two teams that i
cover in the quarterbacks
last year we kept waiting when is the
drew brees announcement and of course he
ended up coming back
even though nbc was waiting in the wings
and i can tell you this is
1 000 accurate tom brady was on his way
to new orleans so of course all of us
can talk about the hypotheticals
that would have applied to the saints if
tom brady had come over and him and sean
payton had gotten in the lab together
what they could have been capable of
i reached out to the saints last week
and i said any chance
we saw drew brees kind of give that
final look
as he's leaving the dome i covered that
game
it was deflating it was heartbreaking to
watch him
throwing a touchdown pass to breeze's
son
and brittany breeze and the kids there
on the field with tom brady and the
tears coming down his face on the bench
and not even getting a hero's send-off
it felt more like a funeral and so you
think to yourself
does he pull a ben roethlisberger and
come back next year
and get the hero send-off that he
deserves for what he and sean have done
for that city collectively i was told no
he is retiring he's just taking his time
you know making this decision and keep
in mind
uh interesting sidebar last week of
course tiger woods was on his way
to see drew reason justin herbert was my
understanding tiger was doing
uh some sort of work for golf tour tv
and so he's supposed to enter
interview drew so maybe drew read the
room and felt like this wasn't the time
either
but in talking to people with that
organization how we handle it moving
forward in terms of media
my sense is that it's coming pretty soon
here do you think brady would have
preferred the saints over the buccaneers
that's a good question i mean sean
payton is a different coach than bruce
arians uh it kind of feels like jimmy
johnson versus barry switzer again to
kind of compare
the two coaches and then you've got
treatment of course being tom brady in
the scenario
it's hard to say i know that tom brady
and sean payton's work ethic
probably would have matched i think
their intensity
would have matched uh but bruce's
approach
sort of it's sort of this hands-off i
don't know if you've ever dealt with
this in your career it's kind of like
the person who sort of hands off
makes you feel like they're not as
invested or as hands-on and it sort of
motivates you a little bit more
we sort of saw the subtlety of that with
bruce arians calling out tom publicly
earlier in the year and so i don't know
and i also think
just for you know just happiness in
terms of living close to the beach there
in florida and the life
that he and gisele and the kids have
which is why they sort of left new
england you know they wanted a change of
pace
i think from a personal standpoint
probably the work-life balance is a
little bit better for him
in florida but again that's just me
thinking out loud i brought this up
about
15 minutes ago the houston chronicles
john mcclane wrote a strong column
saying it's time for the texans to
listen to trade offers for deshaun
watson
that got my attention because we know
john is
as dialed in with the team as much as
any reporter columnist is in
with any team in america in my opinion
if you had a better week's pay is desean
watson with the texans
starting this season doesn't feel like
it uh you know i've talked to some
people that have been involved
with that coaching search and how that
went down there is a real
funny dynamic as it relates to easter
bee
mcnair uh nick casario i think kind of
got
thrown into this unlikely partnership
and i feel like he's trying to right the
ship
he's trying to uh give it a little bit
of stability
but of course when jj watt leaves you
know then you had the vp of
communications amy palsic
she's out the door too bill o'brien of
course you could say what you wanted
about bill but
a lot of people liked bill in that in
that building i think he just probably
took on too many titles he should have
just focused on the coaching as opposed
to gm
but with your star quarterback being
this disgruntled that then i think
becomes a cancer in the locker room it
starts to spread it starts to permeate
i think he's playing hardball and i
think ultimately he's going to end up i
mean i look back to the jamal adams
situation remember he
did not want to be with the jets and i
don't think the nfl is a lot like the
nba that a star can necessarily demand
to trade but we are seeing a lot of
people becoming a little bit more
successful with this
uh in years past but i just feel like
that's a situation that is broken
and in order for houston to sort of turn
the page and had the success that
they're looking for meaningful success
they're probably gonna have to do that
with somebody else that's gonna come in
there and buy into what that system is
down there but it doesn't feel like
desean's gonna be the guy to do it
and i i always find the situation
fascinating when somebody wants
out of a place and then they go to
another place and they look around they
go wait a minute
we we we don't have anybody here we gave
up our draft picks we gave up our best
defensive player
if desean watson goes to the jets you're
going to be giving up
your draft picks you're going to give up
some talent if you go to miami it's
going to be the same thing
he doesn't have any talent in houston
and it feels like it's a lateral move
now you know maybe he'll like that owner
more than he likes the owner
or the front office a little bit more
but to me it seems kind of crazy that
the more valuable you are the more
capital you bring in return
and you're gonna be it's gonna be a
lateral move it's two steps forward two
steps back
that's a great point a lot of people
don't think about the things that you
have to
put around a quarterback in order to be
successful that's why a lot of the
quarterbacks that are successful are on
that first
contract because you're able to put the
pieces around them which is again going
back to the cowboy application
when dak prescott was making in the 400
000
range sure it was easy to you know pay
your running back and your wide
receivers and your offensive linemen
and defensive players but when you start
talking about you're eating up 20 30
of the cap it's really really hard to
put those pieces around you in order to
be meaningful the reason why tom brady
was
so so successful for so long in new
england is he always joked that giselle
made a lot of the money so he was able
to give him a hometown discount
now to be fair a lot of quarterbacks
can't do that
but to your point i think when these
guys want to go to other teams and it
cost them picks in order for them to
restock
the kitchen cabinet it is very very hard
for you to find meaningful success uh
before i let you go do you want to play
the j.j watt game of where you think
he'll end up
oh good question i love seeing how a lot
of these teams have been
lobbying for them i will tell you it
will absolutely not be dallas so that's
easy
who are some of the other ones that you
want to throw at me um
well i'm going to take green bay off
because i don't think that takes any
real risk or any uh great insight to go
boy he could go back to wisconsin where
he played his college ball
i'm gonna give you buffalo cleveland
tennessee buffalo
and tennessee the most intriguing to me
i really think
buffalo would be i just i became such a
fan of the bills last year and what
they're building there and it was
a slow impatient process but it feels
good like it's got a really healthy
vibrant locker room but i also think if
you've ever seen mike vrabel
at a pro day i saw him uh it was god
and at oliver down at houston i needed a
bull in the ring
with the guy as a defensive player
you've got to love
a guy like mike rabel wait he was there
they were hitting each other
yes mike frable was was 1 000
participating in a bowling ring exercise
it was amazing and he's a true player
like players coach the guys
love mike frable i mean i don't know if
you've ever seen bus and the boys and
taylor the one and will compton's
podcast he'll get the bus with the guys
and
i could see tennessee if i had to pick
right now
if tennessee can figure out a way to get
it done that would be an outstanding
destination for them and kind of what an
interesting
send-off that you go to a team that used
to be the houston oilers in essence
so there's sort of a pettiness there so
i think that would be intriguing
jane great work always great to talk to
you we appreciate your time thank you
you as well tell the dana ty jane slater
nfl network reporter